get ready for a modern approach to your
favorite mexican cuisine
la nera cocina and lounge is set to open
in downtown summerlin
this month and here to tell us all about
is concept development chef this is
lanny welcome to show eleni thank you
very much and israel castro as well
welcome gentlemen thank you thank you
first off let's start with the name
what's the meaning of the name so
lanetta pretty much translates to the
truth
right and um at the core of what we're
doing we're taking
traditional mexican flavors making it
bigger bolder stronger
just better in a lot of different ways
and as you can see we're
unapologetically unique
and he's the new chef coach i don't know
where that's right it was right there
it's right there's the hashtag
unapologetically unique this is so great
you brought so much food let's talk
about the menu and some of the stuff you
have here and then chef israel you're
gonna cook for us today as well
so i'm going to be making um the
cauliflower
this is our take down on the cauliflower
the cauliflower is blue why is it blue
so we actually use a blend of different
types of cauliflower so we have purple
green white
and we have gold cauliflower in there um
and now what chef is
sauteing this tell me about that big
pile of meat over there what is that and
i know it's inconspicuous over in the
corner
um but when we made this for the owner
we set it down in front of him he
literally goes
wtf okay all right so that's what it's
called on the menu it's called the wtf
so we have uh montego polenta
and then that's a braised short rib it's
a four
to five pound braised short rib wow um
along with some fried onions but
that montago polenta is it looks
delicious
and so we're sauteing our cauliflower
here what's the next step what are we
putting in next all right so now we're
going to serve it
it's all done ready to go put it on a
plate here put on a plate here and then
we
you have a taco that's suspended by
something here what's this yeah so this
is this is our uh 24 carat taco
um we ran short of time i apologize it
should have gold on it
okay but um we ran a little short on
time uh but we have um
we have steak we have fried onions and
we have a truffle cheese fondue in there
and it comes just like this uh suspended
you bring it to the table it's suspended
to someone to eat it because you know
hanging tacos are normal so
what makes this what makes your mexican
restaurant
different from other restaurants here in
las vegas so we hype up the
presentations we hype up the flavors
um chef israel is really really
passionate about the flavors and the
sauces and the tradition of the food
i like to get a little bit wacky with it
so then that's how we come up with
the dishes that we come up with i want
to try something what do you want to try
here let's do the cauliflower contour
okay
and let me this is our signature
crema yeah this looks delicious
now also to talk about real quick the
interior i heard you have uh some like a
sugar glass thing going on as well yeah
so we're going to have stained glass
we're going to have a
huge sugar tree behind sugar behind one
of our two bars
um and then we're going to have
latticework lots of greenery
this amazing um wooden uh looking floor
mm-hmm how is that oh so good yeah that
is delicious
a little spice on top there as well this
is so good opening date what is it
uh well we're opening in uh in august we
are taking reservations currently but
we're we're still figuring out the exact
opening all visitors a month thank you
so much
we have to tackle that meat i'll go for
that thank you guys rocky we'll send it
over to you
you need to send that plate over to me
jc that smells good